what's up everybody welcome back to my
channel Richard on data if you're new
here my name is Richard and this is the
channel where we talk about all things
data data science statistics and
programming this is my data science
statistics tutorial series where I give
you all the statistics knowledge that
you need to conquer the data science
world let's talk about probability today
so probability lays the foundation for
the overwhelming majority of all of
statistics now in the day-to-day of your
job you're not necessarily going to
dabble directly with probability
calculations every day but you do need
to have a healthy appreciation for
probability and how it ties together
with statistical concepts well today
we're gonna talk about one of the most
important concepts in probability and by
extension all of statistics all together
and that's Bayes rule now before we get
into Bayes rule there are a few other
probability rules that are helpful to
understand now there are tons and tons
of different probability rules out there
and I'm not gonna cover all of them in
this video but there are a few that you
should know first so let's suppose you
have two events and let's call them a
and B now when you see probability of a
given B that's basically saying what's
the probability that a occurs if we're
given the fact that B occurs so the
probability of a given B is equal to the
probability of a and B both occurring
divided by just the probability of B
occurring that's the definition of
conditional probability pretty
straightforward right it's also helpful
to think about the probability of one of
the events occurring in relation to the
other one so the probability of B is
just equal to the probability of B given
a time's the probability of a plus the
probability of B given a complement
times the probability of a complement
where a complement is just a doesn't
happen so the probability of a
complement is just one minus the
probability of a now this rule is
actually pretty intuitive when you think
about it because all it is is breaking
down the probability of B across both
scenarios what happens when a occurs and
what happens when a doesn't occur
now one other super important
probability rule takes place when the
events a and B are independent of each
other so when that's the case
probability of a and B is equal to the
product of those individual
probabilities so just probability of a
time's the probability of B now again
this is only the case when events a and
B are independent and this doesn't
necessarily directly relate to Bayes
rule but this is probably the single
most important rule in probability other
than Bayes rule now as far as Bayes rule
is concerned it's a very simple formula
it's just the fact that the probability
of a given B is equal to the probability
of B given a time's the probability of a
divided by the probability of B simple
that's all there is to it
that rule is going to be true regardless
of whether the events a and B are
independent or not and it's a fairly
straightforward exercise to derive - now
it's a simple rule but it has incredibly
powerful implications that's all
wonderful and everything but I think the
power of Bayes rule is best demonstrated
with an example so let's suppose there's
some disease out there and 2% of the
country has that disease now let's also
say there's a test developed for it and
that test is 99% sensitive as well as
99% specific so what that means is if
you have the disease there's a 99%
chance you'll get a positive result from
the test if you don't have the disease
there's a 99% chance that you'll get a
negative result but now we want to flip
the question and we want to ask let's
suppose you get a positive test what's
the actual probability that you have the
disease then so we can use Bayes rule to
tackle this problem and let's just start
by defining the two events we have event
a and that's having the disease and we
have event B and that's having a
positive test all we have to do here is
use Bayes rule so we have the
probability of a given B equals the
probability of B given
a times the probability of a that's over
the probability of the B which we're not
given directly here but we can solve for
that using this extended form here
because we're basically given all the
rest of this information let's start
with the numerator the probability of B
given a that is the probability of
having a positive test given you have
the disease we already have that
that's the sensitivity that's 0.99 or
99% we have the probability of a because
we know that 2% of the country has the
disease so that's point o2 or 2% and
these exact two terms are the first part
of the denominator as well the second
part of the denominator is where this
gets pretty interesting so we're
directly given the specificity that is
we have the probability that we get a
negative test result if we don't have
the disease that's 99 percent but
actually if we just do 1 minus that now
suddenly we have the probability that we
get a positive test result if we don't
have the disease now that's actually
probability of B given a complement and
that's point zero one and it's the exact
same exercise just to find the
probability of a compliment that's just
1 minus 0.02 that gives us point nine
eight or the probability that we don't
have the disease so we have everything
that we need in the equation all we have
to do is solve for the probability of a
given B once you do all the math you're
gonna come up with 0.669 so there's only
a sixty six point nine percent chance
that you have the disease if you get a
positive test this phenomenon is going
to be true regardless of how sensitive
and how specific your test is it's
because in the real world there's no
such thing as a 100 percent sensitive
and 100 percent specific test and when
we have a rare event like this like in
our hypothetical example this disease
only affects 2 percent of the population
it's pretty rare so Bayes rule
demonstrates that when you solve for
probability of a given B you don't end
up with the super high probability and
it's why when you
have these rare events in the real world
and you test for them you end up with
this super high false positive rate just
think about it if there's a point six
six nine chance that you actually have
the disease if you test positive that
must mean there's a point three three
one chance that you don't have the
disease if you test positive that's not
great for anything so Bayes rule is
extremely important within the
theoretical statistics context because
it actually lays the foundation for an
entire branch of statistics known as
Bayesian statistics as I'm sure you can
see from the example it has all kinds of
practical applications and it's
particularly extremely important within
the pharmaceutical industry and within
any kind of drug testing context so
whether you're a serious data science or
statistics student or you're just
casually learning this for your own
domain it is important to understand
this rule inside and out what about you
guys do you have a favorite most
interesting application of Bayes rule
let me know in the comments so thanks
everyone for watching this video until
next time richard on data